nabila je sais pas lire son attachée de
presse qui est venu d'avoir tout à
l'heure qu'il veut 10 pensent aciéries
je ne sais pas ce qu'est l'ipad je vous
laisse avec surprise pour moi ce que je
voulais je voulais te dire vont vous
dire te dire un truc assuré à ben si tu
ne demandes en mariage
non simplement je voulais juste te dire
que voilà merci de m'avoir j'ai peur je
crois qu'il y avait un cadeau au moins
un truc comme ça avoir soutenu pendant
tout ce temps avec eux malgré ce soit
pour la télé ou pas pour la télé de pas
avoir lâché c'est tout simple
[Applaudissements]
elle veut dire n oublie pas le truc pour
syrie je croyais que nabila avait un
truc c'est pas pour moi je sais pas
combien d'autres outils comme ça
dans l'histoire nabila et je vais vous
dire et vous le savez si je ne lâche
jamais les gens à qui j'ai travaillé et
nabila jusqu'au lâcherai pas ma chérie
ça va s'arranger pour toi oui
vas-y fais toi plaisir